luz sobre una de las operaciones
policiales más impactantes contra un ex
presidente en eeuu estos documentos
publicados este viernes por el fbi son
el registro de los documentos incautados
el lunes en la residencia del antiguo
mandatario
donald trump en mal halago florida la
oficina federal de investigación
confirma la especulación de los medios
estadounidenses trump si se llevó
documentos clasificados de la casa
blanca a su residencia vacacional
él decide y asegura que entre las 11
colecciones de documentos que se
incautaron figura información ultra
secreta es decir una categoría especial
de información sensible trump lo habían
negado previamente no necesitaban
incautar nada lo podrían haber hecho en
cualquier momento en el que quisieran
sin hacer política e irrumpir en mar a
lago ahora el fbi confirma que está
investigando a camps por una posible
violación de la ley de espionaje entre
otros dos posibles delitos federales es
un caso sobre el que apenas este jueves
el fiscal general emérito garland
entregó detalles y está sacudiendo la
política de la unión americana
todo el mundo está a la expectativa
sobre si la naturaleza de estos
documentos es lo que aparenta entonces
sería algo muy grave según el washington
post los agentes federales estaban
buscando documentos relacionados con
armas nucleares en la residencia de
trump mientras eso se esclarece en el
horizonte aparece la pregunta de si en
caso de ser hallado culpable yo me
quedaría inhabilitado para volverse a
presentar a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024